الحدود الاوكرانيه الرومانيه عند نهر
الدانوب شهدت قصفا روسيا هذا ما اكدته
اوكرانيا التي قالت ان لديها ادله مصوره
تظهر طائرات روسيه مسيره استهدفت الاراضي
الرومانيه خلال هجوم جوي على البنيه
التحتيه لموانئ اوكرانيه من جانبها اعلنت
رومانيا ان الهجمات الجديده في اوكرانيا
المجاوره كانت قريبه جدا من الحدود اما
سكان المناطق المجاوره لنهر الدانوب
فتحدثوا عن سماع اصوات تفجيرات
لا استطيع ان اقول ما اذا كانت قد سقطت
على الجانب الروماني
لكنها كانت قريبه جدا مقارنه بالتفجيرات
السابقه
وكان الصوت قويا
منذ تعليق الاتفاق الذي سمح لاوكرانيا
بتصدير حبوبها عبر البحر الاسود في تموز
يوليو الماضي كثافه روسيا من قصها لمنطقه
جنوب غرب اوكرانيا الواقعه على الحدود مع
رومانيا حيث توجد موانئ وبنيه تحتيه مهمه
لهذه التجاره من جانب اخر زار الرئيس
الاوكراني فولودي ميرسي من تقدم الواقعه
في شرق البلاد على خط الجبهه مع القوات
الروسيه والتقى بعدد من الجنود
يشرفنا ان نكون هنا اليوم واشكركم من
اعماق قلبي بالنيابه عن الشعب الاوكراني
باكمله على قوتكم ودفاعكم عن بلدنا
وحدودنا انتم تضحون بانفسكم مقابل كل شبر
من ارضنا الاصليه المستقله على ممتن لكم
واتمنى لكم الصحه والنصر هذه الزياره
للرئيس الاوكراني تاتي بعد ان حققت كييف
الاسبوع الماضي تقدما في هجومها المضاد
الذي تشونه ضد رو